ils sont venus de tous les coins de la
martinique pour embrasser leur foi
chrétienne
[Applaudissements]
entre amis ou en famille les voici
rassemblés pour la fête de l'esprit
saint mais surtout pour vivre et
partager un moment ensemble
[Musique]
un temps fort où l'on chante ou monde
ans comme ici la venue de l'esprit saint
sur les apôtres un temps fort avec un
message entretenir la monuc dans les
foyers atteint un moment en famille
justement c'est pas toujours possible et
là c'est l'occasion et on a envie que la
parole de dieu et l'esprit synthes de
famille celle qui unit votre exactement
quand tout va mal quand on a des soucis
ou quand il ya de l'énervement au foyer
des disputes ben c'est l'esprit saint
qui nous rassemble la famille c'est plus
convivial et pis ça peut-être ça peut
être n'est pas aidé des liens riches et
variées celui lui même une garde-robe
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils baissent les la
martinique les jeunes antillais et qu'on
a plus on n'a plus autant le sentiment
d'être dans une famille qui semble se
reconnaît on à pu éclater par par le
monde peut éclater par le voilà par
l'ambiance dans une culture qui passe
forcément la nôtre est donc retrouver
l'esprit de famille
le petite famille mais aussi de grandes
familles voilà là il ya cela il ya seul
enfin voilà ce qui arrive encore voilà
c'est ça c'est un trésor que la
martinique a encore il faut pas qu'elle
le permet
ce moment de partage en famille
contribuer au travail pour la paix
sociale et le bien commun
grâce à ces louanges et ses prières je
semble avoir fait sa demeure dans les
coeurs